Thanks for joining today.
This is going to be another private live Q&A.
And I'll do my best to answer questions in
two different forms.
We will alternate between questions that were
submitted ahead of time and questions in the
live feed.
I'm going to start with some of the questions
that were submitted beforehand and then people
can add questions to the chat.
The more specific, the better.
The broader they are, the harder it will be
for me to answer.
If they're really long, I will probably also
skip them so try to keep things very concise.
Let me just take a look at a few of the questions
here that are marketing and PR slash launch focused. It'll be fun for me to stretch these muscles since I haven't
done anything specific to these type of topics
in quite a long time.
So here it goes.
The first question that I have in front of
me is from Jon.
I'm going to keep last names out of it, but
J-O-N.
"If you were going to launch a new fast casual
restaurant, how would you gather the crowd
before building the restaurant, i.e., making
sure people would come when it opens?"
Well, the theme that I think is going to recur
in many of my answers is one of risk mitigation.
Perhaps I'm known by some or thought of by
some as a risk taker because I do things like
invest in early state startups, which tend
to go to zero.
I would say a very high percentage, maybe
50 to 70 percent of my investments, go to
zero.
But you have to keep in mind a number of other
factors, and this relates to poker and other
games of skill that are blended with a high
degree of chance and part of that is, say,
bankroll, bet sizing, knowing your maximum
downside compared to your maximum upside.
That's just a frame perspective that I would
like to present as one, I look through for
evaluating almost any type of question like
this, any type of opportunity, any type of
risk.
Coming back to fast casual restaurant, what
would I do?
How would I gather the crowd before building
the restaurant?
I would look at low risk, capped downside
ways of experimenting with this concept.
For instance, in Austin, Texas where my home
base is, you see many successful restaurants
begin as food trucks.
Why?
Because the build out, of course, is much
less, the regulations surrounding food trucks
in some respects far less onerous than those
of restaurants, and you could potentially
prototype taking that type of approach.
A even lower cost approach could be having
a popup in another restaurant.
When I lived in San Francisco, there were
a number of restaurants that were later successful
that began as popups.
Say Thursday nights, or probably an off night,
so maybe a Monday or a Tuesday night in a
given retail location where they are effectively
renting the infrastructure of a preexisting
restaurant.
Now, I'll leave it to you and your lawyers
to determine the legality of that, but nonetheless,
many successful restaurants I'm aware of in
San Francisco began that way.
And it was important they began that way because
they never got it right immediately out of
the gate.
I think it would be a big mistake to just
YOLO all of your chips in at once and try
this concept hoping that the crowds will get
there, or assuming the crowds will congregate
if you haven't really kicked the tires, so
another option would be a popup in another
restaurant.
There's a book.
It's out of date, it is out of print, probably,
called Guerilla Financing, that may also give
you some ideas for how to bootstrap in different
capacities.
I found that book very helpful when I was
bootstrapping one of my first companies.
But the point here is really to identify the
risk factors and this relates to an exercise
that I do at least once a quarter, many of
you have heard of it, called fear-setting.
That was the topic of my last TED Talk, which
has, I think, 10 million views or so now.
Identifying the risk factors and going down
the list, risk by risk, and trying to identify
how you can either eliminate those or mitigate
the likelihood of them occurring.
For instance, if you had a popup and you wanted
to try to draw some type of crowd, and really
your goal is iteration and improvement of
your concept, of your menu, of the experience.
You could partner potentially with, say, organizations
or groups who would stand to benefit from
a rev share.
I'm making this up.
I don't know exactly what fast casual refers
to here.
Let's say it's fast healthy.
You could approach local CrossFit gyms or
gyms of some type and say, "Hey, for every
person you send to this restaurant, I will
give you..."
What do you care?
100 percent of the profit.
You don't have to give them 10 percent.
You don't actually need to make a profit as
long as you break even.
Beyond covering cost, you could just say,
"I will give you all of the revenue that comes
from any of your members you send to this
restaurant."
Because, again, what you're trying to gather
is feedback first and foremost so that you
can improve before you have more sunk cost
in some type of, say, food truck or retail
location.
All right, let me take one more here and then
I'll jump into the questions in the chat and
we'll see where it goes.
Here we go.
Here's a question from Matt.
"What would be your approach if you wanted
to raise awareness of a new productivity tool?
It's genuinely different from any of the approaches
taken so far and helps people apply the great
advice they know, but don't follow.
Easy to pick up and use just minutes a day.
There's free versions, but I have no list
or platform to gain initial traction.
Share to bloggers, podcasts, et cetera in
the space.
Any advice?
Welcome and thanks for the counsel and company
over the years."
I have a few recommendations here and the
first is really observing people, ideally,
not just asking people.
I'll just draw a contrast here.
If you think you have a great idea for a business,
it could be a product based business or service
based business, and you ask your friends,
"Would you buy this?
Would you pay X amount for such and such a
thing?"
In most cases, we will have some friends,
maybe most of our friends will say, "Yes,
I would absolutely do that."
However, their behavior changes a bit when
you then put out your hand and say, "Fantastic,
I'm taking pre-orders, I'll give you a 20
percent discount.
Could I take that payment now?"
The point is, asking for opinions and getting
people to take action are two very, very different
things.
And likewise, observing people using a tool
is very different from asking them how they
might use a tool.
What I would suggest in this case is before
you even think about launching, make sure
you're solving a problem that people want
solved.
If something has never been done before, I
find this very important to put under scrutiny
and really pay attention to.
One of my first steps might be paying 20 people
to use it.
That might sound funny.
If there are free options available, why would
I pay someone?
You're paying someone for their time and feedback.
This will sound very similar to my first answer,
and you could pay 20 people to use it and
observe exactly the flow through the product,
exactly their feedback, encourage them to
speak out loud.
There are services that provide for this.
Usertesting.com would be one example.
I haven't used it personally, but I know startups
who have.
May be beyond your price range, but you could
also take lower tech options or off the shelf
options.
You could have people record themselves using
something like Loom, which is a tool I use
a lot for screen capture for training employees
and contractors, feedback on various designs.
You could have them simply capture their experience
on, say, laptop with something like Loom,
and then share those with you.
And you could find these people to test your
product on Craigslist or really just about
anywhere, or you could do this in person.
I know a number of well-known CEOs who began
their companies that now have 1,000, 2,000,
5,000 employees by recording user testing
sessions in person with video.
You could simply have them in front of you
at their laptop, encourage them to speak out
loud.
Then, you have an iPhone or something and
you're simply recording the screen as they
walk through it so that you can correlate
things properly.
But I would say begin with more intelligence
gathering.
That's where I would start, and then in terms
of how to get the word out, sending free software
to bloggers, podcasts that are in the space
can't hurt, but you're going to need to have
a good pitch.
I get sent, or I should say people tend to
send me thousands of different pitches per
day, literally thousands.
The vast majority I simply deflect because
I don't have the bandwidth, nor does my team
have the bandwidth to even digest or read
these pitches.
I would think of other approaches.
The way that I have tackled this with each
book launch, as an example, is looking for
the neglected but powerful channel and then
also the nascent, up-and-coming channel that
is ramping in influence.
For the first book, The 4-Hour Workweek, that
was bloggers, for instance.
Most people were like, "Blogs, what the hell
is a blog?" in 2005.
But at the time, I knew that they were pulling
more weight for book sales in some respects
than the darlings of network television and
syndicated radio at the time so I paid a lot
of attention to that.
For The 4-Hour Chef, it was podcasts.
This was in 2012, after which I launched my
own podcast in 2014.
I would also look at the landscape of tools.
And another question I would ask is, which
of these tools or platforms are you actually
going to engage in for the long term?
You don't have to decide that upfront, but
where do your natural skills and enthusiasm
overlap such that you will have staying power?
If you're not going to have staying power,
chances are, beyond a flash in a pan, it's
not going to be helpful.
You can still use one-time-only PR approaches,
much like I really targeted Digg.com, D-I-G-G.com,
founded by my friend Kevin Rose way back in
the day to try to get on the homepage for
launching The 4-Hour Body because I understood
the power of Digg at that time for acting
as a front-page shopping list, a tastemaking
service of sorts, much like landing at the
top of Hacker News or something like that
today.
Those are a few thoughts, and I will come
back to some related themes in the next question
and then I'm going to go to some in the live
Q&A, so don't worry, guys.
Here's the third one.
This is from Josh, and I'm just going down
in order that I have them in front of me.
This is a question related to advising tech
companies.
"When you were advising tech companies, what
were your most successful marketing campaigns/contribution
to the companies?
Any notable misses you're willing to share?"
For those who have not seen the range of companies
that I've worked with, you can go to angel.co/Tim.
You can see quite a handful there.
In terms of most successful marketing campaign/contributions,
contributions I'm going to focus on because
oftentimes where I have aimed to help has
been unrelated to anything immediately public
facing.
For instance, for TaskRabbit, way in the early
days, I helped Leah raise her first round
of financing when the company was actually
completely named differently based, I believe,
just in Cambridge or in the Boston area, and
we met in the Bay area.
I helped her to syndicate her financing.
I introduced her to lead investors who ended
up helping her raise money and then much later
that company was sold to IKEA.
In other cases, it could be related to helping
companies apply needed leverage or user pressure
for, say, regulatory purposes.
I was very active in this capacity with Uber,
particularly with some precedent-setting examples
where situations were very, very high stakes
in places like Washington, DC.
With my platform and via other types of back
channel work, that's a separate category of
help that I sometimes provide.
In terms of marketing, I think the most notable
example is probably — and there are many,
many, many examples, but the most notable,
well-known example is probably the build to
business competition that I helped to design
with Tobi and Harley of Shopify.
If you want to read more about that, there's
a fair amount out there.
There is a piece in Fortune magazine called
"The Invisible Selling Machine" about Shopify.
This was a huge piece in the magazine some
time ago, and it goes into quite a bit of
detail about my involvement in the build a
business competition, and then overall what
that looked like.
That was very, very, very high ROI, high leverage
for Shopify.
And if you don't have a Fortune subscription,
you can go to the Web Archive, I think it's
just web.archive.org, otherwise known as The
Wayback Machine.
You can grab a snapshot and take a look at
that article.
All right, let's hop into the live feed and
see what we got here.
All right, we got a lot of questions.
I'm going to do my best to get to some of
them.
All right, bear with me a minute.
Okay, we've got a lot of good questions.
All right, well, I'll take a self-interested
one first.
This is from Joe Chen.
"What is your biggest project/challenge at
the moment and how can we support you?"
I do have a very absurd and I think hilarious
and fun art project coming out in the not
too distant future, so keep an eye out for
that.
At the very least, just taking a break to
laugh at the whole thing when it comes out.
That's how you could support, but I'll keep
moving here.
All right, this one is from Scott.
"What's a takeaway or lesson you wish more
of us listeners paid attention to/followed
through with?"
I would say in this day and age, probably
the low-information diet as described in The
4-Hour Workweek and here's my phone here.
I have not had any social apps on this phone
in two years, and that's not because I broadcast
that for sitting on my moral high horse.
It's because I understand that it is playing
a dangerous game to assume that you can use
willpower and self-control.
At the very least, it is exhausting and you
can save your mental calories for something
more important.
To have this type of addictive technology
embedded into your phone with notifications
that you're subject to 24/7, through which
algorithms are being wielded against you that
have billions of dollars in teams of data
scientists and UI experts behind them, I think
it's unnecessarily challenging to subject
yourself to that and to expect to be able
to overtake that and single task effectively.
And some people say, "Well, I have better
self-control.
You can just use self-control."
That may be true, but I could also have junk
food littered all over my house, and I can
make the same argument.
I could say, "Well, if I have enough self-control,
I won't eat the junk food," but it's a hell
of a lot easier just to remove all the junk
food from your house.
I do think the low-information diet, this
applies not just a social media, but certainly
any type of push news, which could just be
reactively picking up the newspaper every
day when you go to grab a cup of coffee at
a gas station or something like that.
It doesn't need to be digital, but the low-information
diet, I think is very much underestimated
in its power.
If you can single task for a few hours a day
without any interruption, which is why I use
Do Not Disturb and so on my laptop as well
as frequently as I do, and my phone is almost
always on airplane mode, you will have a huge
competitive advantage over the majority of
people who are — let's just call them knowledge
workers, anyone who works on a computer.
If you have the ability to single task for,
let's just call it, three hours a day in a
single block of time, you have an unbelievable
competitive advantage.
I would say the low-information diet.
All right, let's see what else we have here.
Always takes me a little while to read these
things, so thanks for the patience.
Okay.
This is a question from Renalyn.
"What are your thoughts on Substack as more
of a pull way to get information?"
Yeah, I think that opting into highly curated
sources of information that are either relevant
to you in the near term or actionable to you
in the near term is far superior to being
lost in the waves and chop of online assault
that is uncontrolled, if we're talking about
information.
I think newsletters certainly are far superior.
You can still use them to procrastinate in
the same way that you can use reading books
as a socially acceptable way to procrastinate,
so just be aware of that.
As Kathy Sierra once phrased it to me, "Focus
on just-in-time information, not just-in-case
information."
If you think you might need to act on say,
the contents of a book six to 12 months from
now, it doesn't really do you a lot of good
to read it now is my general feeling.
I would read it closer to the point at which
you need to actually implement it.
But I would say that something like Substack
or newsletters in general I think are superior
in so much as they force you to make decisions
about high-priority/low-priority information
ahead of time so that you're not making all
those decisions on the fly.
Because, look, we're all simple creatures
and the algorithms will beat you, whether
it's just showing a picture of Kim Kardashian
ass or some celebrity or who the hell knows?
It's going to pull you off task.
I don't care who you are, so just keep the
junk food out of your house, metaphorically
speaking.
Let's see.
Comment on Cal Newport and great books on
deep, deep learning, deep work.
I agree with that.
Let's see.
Ila, question, "One of the most enjoyable
parts of your show is listening to your personal
journey and your interviewees' journeys of
transcendence.
Any recent spiritual shifts that you would
not mind sharing?"
I don't mind sharing.
I was actually recently in the mountains of
New Mexico and experienced some of the most
profound and extreme time dilation I've ever
felt, certainly in a sober state with a friend
of mine.
And so we were hiking at altitude on and off
for several days and by, say, day three, thinking
back to the morning of even day two or day
one felt like looking back to three weeks
or four weeks prior.
Being in nature, I think partially contributing
to that was the fact that we changed locations
so many times and that the topography of the
land changed so many times.
It could as well have been four or five different
countries we visited given how different the
landscapes were and the wildlife and so on.
But that time dilation I think highlights
something for me at least, which is there
are different ways to extend or, better said,
I think, expand life, to live in an expansive
state more often.
And many of the, let's just call them post-economic,
extremely wealthy, successful in financial
terms, founders and CEOs and so on, I know
want to extend health span, which I think
is a very worthwhile objective, looking at
science and technology for extending healthy
years.
However, you can live a long time, but almost
never be present.
I'm not saying that's true for these people,
but I know people who live a long time and
they're so preoccupied about the past or the
future or the news or the politician on TV
or whatever, that they have a lot of time
contraction.
Time passes very quickly for them.
What if you could design a life and pre-schedule
experiences such that you have the type of
time dilation I'm talking about, where let's
just say even twice a year, you have two trips
each a week long, and each of those one week
trips actually feels like three months?
Well, have you then in that case, effectively
added — let's just say each one feels like
three months.
Okay, have you added six months to each year
by doing that in terms of your experiential
lifespan?
If so, that's very interesting, right?
Now you're living, let's just call it 50 percent
longer in your remaining years.
Does that have the net/net positive or even
a greater benefit than simply extending your
biological lifespan by that period of time?
I don't know.
I do know that's a question that's been on
my mind and we can certainly pursue both,
but one is available here and now, and the
others are more so a scientific roadmap with
possibilities.
I think this type of time dilation through
very deliberately designed experience and
immersion is very seductive and rewarding.
All right, let's come back.
I think it's Kale.
It might be Kali, I apologize.
I don't know how to pronounce it.
"Love your work, Tim.
Caught up with Derek Sivers in New Zealand
a couple weekends ago.
He told me he missed you."
Well, I miss Derek too.
He's a great guy and has been on the podcast
several times.
If people haven't heard Derek Sivers on the
podcast, they should and I do need to catch
up with him.
Let me come back to some of the questions
that were pre-submitted, answer a handful
of those, and then I'll come back to questions
in the chat.
Feel free to drop them in and I will continue
to answer them.
Let me get back to some of these pre-submitted
questions.
All right, here we go.
This is from Ben.
"We have invented a way, patent pending, to
add a second story to a house without the
owners moving out.
This product and process is revolutionary
for so many people.
However, we keep going back and forth about
whether to create a franchise model or just
to sell the proprietary system that allows
you to do it.
The catch is that it definitely requires training
to use it properly.
Love to get your feedback about how you would
launch it.
Very grateful for you and the value you have
brought to my life."
Well, thank you, Ben.
Here are my first thoughts.
Construction, adding stories, et cetera, does
not sound, at least immediately to me, as
a liability-free endeavor.
I assume there are some risks involved, as
you mentioned, and I think implied that it
definitely requires training to use it properly
and using it properly seems important.
Looking at this again through the lens of
minimizing or capping your downside risk,
I would say a lot of folks think about business
risk in terms of profit and loss.
How much does it cost me to make X?
How much can I sell X for?
What is my margin?
Can I cover my various costs, maybe employees,
et cetera?
But there are other factors that are often
neglected.
In this particular case, there are questions
around legal cost and legal liability.
I know that developing and rolling out a franchise
properly can be very capital intensive if
you're the franchisor, and I wouldn't underestimate
that.
Step number one, I think, in evaluating a
number of these would be running some models
and putting together just basic mathematics
based on conversations with competent legal
counsel, and there are people who specialize,
of course, in both of these.
There is also a great book by Stephen Key
called One Simple Idea: Turn Your Dreams into
a Licensing Goldmine While Letting Others
Do the Work.
That's a great subtitle.
I didn't realize that was a subtitle, but
One Simple Idea by Stephen Key.
He is an exceptionally successful inventor
who generally does not venture, meaning he
doesn't generally manufacture and distribute
and sell product himself.
He's coming up with ideas, often with very
inexpensive prototyping, and then licensing
those ideas to other companies in most cases.
That book I think is worth a read, not because
it is immediately comparable since he's mostly
operating in the world of toys, but I do think
it will raise questions that are valuable
for you.
Another one to look at is Built to Sell.
This is a book by John Warrillow.
If you were ever considering the possibility
of being able to sell this company, and that,
I think, is worth looking at, even if you've
never considered that possibility, because
it will help you to identify where you as
a proprietor, as a business owner, could end
up being a bottleneck, whether it's for scaling
the company or ultimately for not just scaling
it, but selling the company.
I would take a look at that.
And on the legal cost and then liability side,
I would just say one idea that immediately
comes to mind, and this is not legal advice,
please speak to your properly vetted attorney
for this, but potentially there may be the
option of partnering with a larger company
who can run pilot studies or experiments in
implementing this technology.
You could have a licensing fee.
You could have some other type of arrangement.
They could take a potential equity stake in
the company, although that seems potentially
premature at this point.
The reason I bring that up is if they were
willing to test this technology, you could,
and speak to your lawyer, but you could potentially
be added as an additional insured, so named
as an additional insured on their insurance
policies.
It may be relevant to have you added to their
errors and omissions policy, but these are
ways of being covered by their insurance policies
and therefore the premiums that they pay,
which in the early stages, if you're bootstrapping,
could be non-trivial.
Those are just a couple of things that come
to mind in terms of how to launch it.
One of the benefits, again, of possibly partnering
with larger company is they assume the financial
risk, a lot of the legal risk of implementing
this and you can see if it actually catches.
Do people want this?
Can this company sell it?
Can this company implement it without assuming
all of those risks yourself?
All right, let's hop back to the live feed
and see what we got here.
All right.
Let me see.
Seems like we got a couple of things up here.
Bear with — okay, couple of people asking
about the O2 breathing device that Bas Rutten
and I had talked about.
Yes, I have been using it and I've actually
found it tremendously helpful and I don't
think that's purely placebo effect.
I used the O2 trainer to prepare for my extensive
hiking at altitude in New Mexico and I found
it to be very, very helpful and easy to use
and incredibly soreness-inducing.
When you hear Bas say, with the back breathing
as an example, “Don't start with 30 repetitions,
start with 15,” take him at his word.
If you do more than that, you'll feel like
someone hit you with a pickaxe up and down
all of your muscles around your ribcage and
mid back the next day, or two or three.
So it is then seemingly very effective for
stressing and applying a workout to your inspiratory
muscles.
So I, for one, plan on continuing to use that
device.
MIDROLL
All right.
Let's see here.
Let's see.
So this is a question from Meade, I hope I'm
getting your name correct, "Would you please
share any current recommendations that provide
hope or encouragement to a caregiver amid
a chronic medical situation?"
Thank you so very much for sharing your experience.
So first, I'm very sorry that you're in that
situation or someone you know is in that situation.
And the only advice I can really think of
offhand is, I guess, it's twofold.
The first is an interview I did with Dr. BJ
Miller quite a few years ago, who is a hospice
care physician, also a triple amputee who
has helped thousands of people to transition.
So that conversation, which is on some levels,
deeply philosophical.
I still act on and revisit a lot from that
conversation.
I personally found a lot of it incredibly
actionable and impactful.
So I would suggest potentially giving a listen
to that.
And secondly, I would recommend a book that
has been recommended to me several times,
including my friends who have lost parents
unexpectedly, and that is, On Grief and Grieving.
And I'll find the author right now.
On Grief and Grieving by David Kessler and
Elisabeth Kübler-Ross.
And all of the people who have recommended
this book to me have said they wished they
had read it prior to anyone passing away,
that in fact, it also acts as fantastic preparation
and consolation if you may be on the verge
of losing someone.
And we're all on the verge of losing someone
in the grand scheme of things, in the grand
scheme of life.
So that would be a second recommendation.
And apologies if those aren't appropriate,
but given the context I have, those are the
best I can come up with.
All right.
Let me see if I can pull up a few more here.
So there's a question.
This is a question from Carrie, "Can you speak
at all about any current information you or
any other of your previous guests have on
ketamine and bladder damage?"
So for those who have not heard it, I would
suggest listening to my recent episode with
Dr. John Krystal, who's chairman of the psychiatry
department at Yale, an incredible researcher
also in his own right, who along with other
colleagues, pioneered research that identified
the antidepressant effects of ketamine in
humans, speaking in this case of intravenous
administration.
But in that episode, we didn't specifically
discuss bladder damage or urinary tract symptoms.
And there is quite a bit of literature to
support the assertion that these are potential
side effects, especially of recreational use
of ketamine and sometimes goes by the name
ketamine bladder syndrome.
And I would suggest going to PubMed, if you
just search PubMed, P-U-B-M-E-D, and you search
ketamine bladder or ketamine urinary tract,
then quite a few reviews, quite a few papers
will come up.
So in the abstract here, this is "Ketamine
Bladder Syndrome: An Important Differential
Diagnosis When Assessing a Patient with Persistent
Lower Urinary Tract Symptoms."
Abstract, "The recreational use of ketamine
is increasing in popularity due to its dissociative
and paralytic effects, ease of availability
and low cost."
This is from 2012, just to timestamp it.
"However, serious and frequently irreversible
damage to the urinary tract is a recently
recognized side effect of recreational ketamine
use."
And this goes on to present a number of case
studies.
So my understanding is, and this, I'm not
a doctor, I don't play one on the internet,
but my understanding is that this is reasonably
common in recreational use.
But I'm not aware how frequently that pops
up as an adverse event in the clinical trials
that have been done.
And those would be documented in those studies.
So you could certainly look for, say John
Krystal, K-R-Y-S-T-A-L on PubMed and look
at the studies.
And if you get the complete study, not just
the abstract, you can look at the frequency
of adverse events and most certainly something
like that would be included, I imagine.
But you can find more in depth information
on PubMed, which is surprisingly easy to use,
and I find generally quite user friendly,
even though you may need to look up some words
now and again.
Okay, well here's one from Sabrina, "I'm my
own bottleneck in my business.
Is that bad?"
It's not automatically bad.
Depends on what you want to do with your business,
right?
If you are a artisanal high-end leather pantmaker.
And I actually read a case study about such
a person who makes super high-end leather
pants or did at least for people like Sheryl
Crow and Mick Jagger, et cetera, then you
are an artist.
You are the business.
You are the artisan who is producing your
craft.
And if you choose that and you're accepting
the good with the bad, then I think it's 100
percent okay.
Of course, it is.
It just depends on what you're trying to do.
And there is no right answer to that.
I know many business owners who have chosen
not to scale very, very deliberately.
And I actually find those counter examples
to today's gestalt and drive to scale and
build, say public companies or companies that
get acquired to be very refreshing because
it doesn't get as much fanfare.
But there is a book that I haven't read in
a very long time, but I really enjoyed it
when I did called Small Giants.
The subtitle is, Companies That Choose to
Be Great Instead of Big.
And it is a book by Bo Burlingham, B-U-R-L-I-N-G-H-A-M.
So Small Giants.
But I very much enjoyed that book when I read
it.
And in fact, the example I just gave you could
have come from that book.
There's a decent chance that it did.
This question from Al, "What blogs and newsletters
are you excited about reading or receiving
every day?"
There's nothing that I receive every day.
There are at most newsletters that I get once
a week, and there are very few.
I mean, The Microdose, which is from UC Berkeley,
and gives a synopsis of happenings and new
events in the psychedelic spaces of interest
to me.
But very few newsletters.
And in fact, even with other writers I really,
really enjoy — so for instance, bear with
me a second.
So Matt Levine of Bloomberg, for instance,
I think Matt Levine is one of the best writers.
And by best I mean not just prolific, because
that is not the measure, volume is not the
measure, word count is not the measure necessarily
of a good writer, but his combination of volume
and insight, the density of insight to words
per page is staggering.
Nonetheless, I know that I have three or four
friends who read Matt's work religiously,
and I depend on them to forward me specific
snippets or specific newsletters that they
know align with what I am focused on at the
moment.
But if I were to add say, one other newsletter
to my regular consumption rounds, it would
probably be from Matt Levine.
And there are a handful of others I find interesting.
But there's nothing that I get on a daily
basis, and that is by design.
A question from Megan, "What are the first
steps you're planning to take on the animal
communication journey?"
Well, there are a number of them.
And for those who don't know, this is something
that came up in my recent conversation with
Dr. Gabor Maté.
One of them is identifying, one of the steps
is identifying where animal communication
can actually be tested, if this makes sense.
So and this comes up at all sorts of fields.
If you're trying to find an expert, right?
How can you identify, let's just take a different
field.
There are many folks in the US and elsewhere
who claim to be animal tracking experts.
But how can you as a non-expert in animal
tracking assess if someone is full of shit
or the real McCoy?
The short answer is generally you can't.
But if you look for the exception, and the
exception is any of system or company or organization
within which trackers are actually tracked
themselves numerically, then you can start
to get somewhere.
And in my case, I ended up looking at safari
outfits in Africa that keep records on trackers
because they could identify, for instance,
that the average for, let's just call it leopard
tracking, successful leopard tracking during
these hours is 23 percent, but so and so has
an average of 71 percent as a success rate.
And you get almost major league baseball statistics,
animal by animal, time of day by time of day
for these different trackers.
And then you can start to assess on an objective
level who is actually good.
This is even more difficult with something
like animal communication depending on how
we interpret it.
But I would, I'm starting with, I would say
two things.
The first is revisiting dog and training and
mammalian training.
Although a lot of such training is behavioral
shaping and using nonverbal cues.
I'm okay with that though, by communication,
I'm not limiting that to verbal cues.
So it could be using a clicker.
I'm going to be revisiting Susan Garrett,
who is a master dog trainer I had on the podcast.
How do you know a dog trainer is good?
Well, for me, I looked for sports.
So she is a multiple time, if I'm remembering
correctly, national agility champion with
her dogs.
And these are objective measures, which I
like.
I like to start there.
And then secondly, I'm very interested in
looking at different methods of hunting and
how hunters interact with animals.
The most obvious example that comes to mind
for me being elk, where not only are bull
calls being used as a way of drawing in bull,
but also cow calls of different types.
And there are actually elk-calling competitions
where people get on stage and are asked by
a panel of judges to produce different types
of calls.
And it's mind-boggling.
I mean, it's very, very, very impressive what
some of these hunters can do.
So I think those are two places where I'll
start.
There are other examples that are of interest
to me that I've looked into and will probably
spend more time on.
Equine therapy is quite interesting from a,
I suppose more of a physical kinesthetic,
interactive perspective.
But those are some of the jumping off points
that I expect I'll spend some more time on.
A question from Dan, and then I'm going to
come back to the PR and marketing stuff with
some of the questions I have here.
Dan, "What is your protocol prior to taking
a three-day fast to get your body ready?"
So when I fast, again, not medical advice.
Talk to your doctor before doing any fasting.
You can't even get approval to do extended
fasting.
Probably couldn't get IRB approval to do three-day
fast in humans, depending on the circumstance,
it'd be very hard.
It's really hard to do scientific research
on extended fasting these days.
In any case, what I typically do for a three-day
fast is, let's just say my fast is going to
begin after an early dinner on Thursday night.
That is typically how I will line things up.
Don't do your first three-day fast in the
middle of the week.
It's going to fuck up your whole situation
and you're going to send a lot of emails you're
going to have to do damage control on.
So don't do that.
So leading up to then, if my last meal is,
let's just say Thursday at 6:00 p.m., what
I will do in the two days prior is I will
get on a sub maintenance calorie ketogenic
diet.
So I will be having smaller meals than usual
that are going to be predominantly fat.
So let's just say hamburger with some cheese
and maybe a side salad, right?
But I will be consuming fewer calories than
thought necessary to maintain my lean body
mass.
And you can calculate resting metabolic rate
and try to figure out what that is based on
all sorts of factors.
So lower calorie keto for maybe two days beforehand
with a fair amount of exercise to deplete
glycogen stores a bit.
And then last meal would be a smaller keto
meal on Thursday.
Sleep as long as possible.
That's part of the reason the timing is the
way I that I set it up.
And then beginning on Friday, what I try to
do is prior to that, set up Friday for phone
calls so that I can be moving.
So I try to get away from my laptop and move.
This will actually be very, very helpful for
a whole host of reasons.
But on Friday, as soon as I get up, I get
a huge bottle of water, I fill it full of
electrolytes like LMNT, which is what I've
been using for a couple years and maybe put
in a little bit of lemon just for flavoring,
non-caloric.
And then I will walk and talk.
So I'll briskly walk for three to five hours
minimum and take my phone calls.
This will help on a number of levels.
You will still have some residual glycogen
and you will break down some of that into
glucose so that your brain can actually function
on Friday.
And you can have a bit of caffeine.
Don't overdo the caffeine.
One of the mistakes that novice fasters make
is they feel a little sluggish so they end
up having way too much caffeine and then that
inhibits sleep.
If you do not supplement with electrolytes,
there's a good chance that you're going to
experience lower back pain.
I won't get into the mechanisms responsible
for that, but very often you'll have lower
back pain, especially if you do more than
a three-day fast.
And you'll have a cholinergic response where
your heart rate is really fast.
So I always supplement with electrolytes these
days.
And it's water only.
Now if you want to have, say, some black coffee
with a little bit of pure heavy cream, a hundred
percent fat or a little bit of coconut oil,
I don't think that inhibits most of the beneficial
effects that we're looking for.
Okay.
So then that's Friday.
Then Saturday, again, same deal.
Right?
You don't have to walk as much, but it will
still be somewhat helpful.
And in fact, a little bit of weight training
can feel very good cognitively.
And then Sunday, you're going to break fast,
right?
Not at breakfast time, but that night.
So then Sunday night around, let's just call
it six, seven, whenever, you would have your
first meal leading out of the fast.
And there are all sorts of superstition around
this.
Like, "Oh, you have to eat grated cabbage,
and you have to do this and you've got to
start with some unpasteurized fruit juice
and this, that, and the other thing."
My uninformed take or semi-informed take is
that that seems kind of nonsensical to me.
If we were starving in any circumstance, would
our body and evolutionary drives require us
to start with shredded cabbage?
I mean, it just doesn't make any sense to
me.
So when I break fast, I'm generally breaking
it with another keto meal.
Because I like to extend some of the effects
of the fast or at least the ketogenic diet
for a day or two afterwards.
You don't have to do that, but I will very
often break the fast with something akin to
the meals that I used for the preparation
for the fast.
And those are some of the thoughts that I
have on at least how I personally prepare
for three-day fasts and implement three-day
fasts.
Your mileage will vary and please get professional
medical advice.
Let me take a look at some of the questions
that were sent in advance.
This is a question from Dave, "Are you seeing
any trends in successful nonprofit launches?
I'm kicking off an effort to generate and
share coastal resilience data."
All right, so the subject area, coastal resilience
data, certainly of interest to me.
And what I would say is study trends in the
for-profit world.
Launching nonprofit ventures, launching for-profit
ventures, principles are exactly the same
in my experience.
I think some nonprofits have done a very good
job with promotional efforts.
I think DonorsChoose and Charity: Water are
two that come to mind immediately that are
very good and have for a very long time been
very good at this.
So you might take a look at those.
But I would really borrow from the private
sector.
The stakes are generally higher, the talent
and competition more intense in the for-profit
world.
So a lot of the mediocre or B minus approaches
will just get massacred before they ever see
the light of day.
They won't actually overcome any degree of
competition.
So I suggest that you look at the for-profit
world.
Now for fundraising purposes, fundraising
is slightly different than selling a product,
although I think there's more in common than
there are differences to be perfectly honest.
But I would look at any number of older examples.
We don't need to reinvent the world here.
So what I would say is, and I've mentioned
this book before, but I will repeat it because
it'll come up again in a second just as a
proof point.
So I'll give you evidence that this actually
does work.
The 22 Immutable Laws of Marketing.
Get the older one, not the for the internet,
which is horribly out of date.
Get the older one that has the beer examples,
the airline examples.
The 22 Immutable Laws of Marketing, and take
a close look at that.
Also read "1,000 True Fans" by Kevin Kelly,
that's on kk.org, "1,000 True Fans."
And last but not least, read The 80/20 Principle
by Richard Koch, K-O-C-H.
And the first two of those, "1,000 True Fans"
will take 10 minutes to read, The 22 Immutable
Laws of Marketing, some of which is not going
to apply, but a lot of which will, will take
you maybe an hour or two to read.
And then The 80/20 Principle will probably
take you a day or two to read.
So you might sequence it in that way, but
I would focus on those.
And then I'll give you maybe an unorthodox
recommendation.
But in 5-Bullet Friday, my newsletter.
If you're not on it, check it out, tim.blog/friday.
About two million people subscribe.
Let me take a look at what I included recently
that I found led to a series I was very interested
in.
And it is a YouTube series.
Bear with me a sec.
Nope, that's not the one.
Okay.
Guys, come on.
Man, I've been doing 5-Bullet Friday for a
long time, every week for I don't know, how
many years?
Eight years, nine years, 10 years.
Okay, so here we go.
Business Insider has a YouTube video series
about business collapses.
And one of them I found fascinating called
"How the Beanie Babies Frenzy Collapsed."
That's an 11-minute video.
And when you watch "How the Beanie Babies
Frenzy Collapsed," which I recommend, because
it may relate to a lot of the implosions that
we have seen and will continue to see with
some of the activities in NFTs and so on.
But these historical examples can not only
teach you a lot about what doesn't work, but
about what works.
So embedded in these how, fill in the blank,
collapsed are certain principles that I think
you can also borrow and apply.
So that series by Business Insider I think
is exceptional.
I looked at a few of the videos and found
them all very, very instructive, and each
one had a number of takeaways for me personally.
So I would encourage also taking a look at
that.
I'll do one more and then I'm going to come
back to the live chat.
This is going to serve as both a proof point
and a question.
So this is from Joel, "Ahoy, Tim."
This is going to be a little long, but I'm
going to read it anyway.
"I love your Q and As.
I really appreciate the opportunity to hear
curious questions from the gigantic diversity
of people you've helped.
So thank you for this.
"My question relates to The 22 Immutable Laws
of Marketing by Al Ries and Jack Trout.
Also, thank you for introducing me to this
book in 2016.
It has since helped me build a business with
1.8 million lifetime sales from making porcelain
coffee books."
Okay.
So this stuff works, guys.
It does work.
And I can't take credit because I learned
from the book as well and have applied it.
So I'm simply passing along something that
no doubt was introduced to me by any number
of people.
All right, back to the description and the
question.
"The problem is that I handcraft each mug
with my bare hands using porcelain clay and
a pottery wheel.
I'm living the dream making a living as an
artist, and I'm obsessed with the art of the
pottery mug, but it's pretty hard.
And I'm still working on long term sustainable
profits.
I've thought about outsourcing to China, the
porcelain capital of the world, but that's
fraught with problems.
"So instead of trying to grow by selling billions
of cheap mugs, I've decided to grow my business
by handcrafting mugs worthy of a higher price."
I agree with this approach.
I think that you do not want to be engaged
in a race to the bottom.
"However," back to the text, "That means creating
a sort of luxury brand.
Since this doesn't exist today, we're focusing
on law number one, the law of leadership that
says it's better to be first than it is to
be better.
These mugs are art, but they're not better
than the world's best sculptures and paintings,
which often sell for millions of dollars each
or fancy-ass, diamond-encrusted purses that
sell for tens of thousands of dollars each.
But I believe it could be the first mug to
inspire people globally as a piece of art
that you can enjoy your morning coffee from
every day.
Law number four, the law perception has been
one factor that helped me sell mugs for 500
to 1,000 dollars per mug."
Nicely done.
"But the vast majority of customers want a
cheaper mug.
How would you evaluate whether or not a luxury
mug business is worth pursuing?
And if you determined it was worth pursuing,
what would you do to grow?"
All right.
Let's hop into this.
So there are a few books I would recommend
checking out, Joel.
As usual, I have many book recommendations.
So the first, which I've not read in a very,
very long time, but may be helpful, is a book
called Selling to the Affluent.
That's by Thomas Stanley.
And you may be able to find a summary and
to determine if it is in any way relevant
to you.
One way that I assess books oftentimes is
trying to find a Wikipedia page for the book,
which will give you a synopsis of some type.
So Selling to the Affluent by Thomas J. Stanley,
I found certainly helpful at one point when
I was considering many of the same questions
for different businesses.
The other book may sound a little funny at
first because it would seem to be anti advice,
but it is called Deluxe, subtitle, How Luxury
Lost Its Luster.
There's a lot of alliteration here.
It's hard for my tongue to get out right now.
But this book is by Dana Thomas.
I hope I'm getting the pronunciation right.
Deluxe is the name of the book, How Luxury
Lost Its Luster.
And it talks about different high-end luxury
brands and how some of them have compromised
themselves by outsourcing supply chains and
making other poor strategic decisions.
But embedded through the whole story and the
various case studies is the cocktail of ingredients
that have made some of the most durable luxury
brands the world has ever seen, at least in
the last several centuries.
So I really greatly enjoyed this book.
It's got 3.9 out of five on Goodreads.
For your particular case, it's about 400 pages
long, I think that is worth reading for a
whole host of reasons.
And then what I would say is to your last
two questions, "How would you evaluate whether
or not a luxury mug businesses were pursuing?"
So I think that, and I have this predisposition
to, it's very tempting to try to figure it
out, right?
To sit down with pen and paper, look at a
few databases and decide, is this worth doing?
Is it not worth doing?
That can be very time consuming.
It can also be misleading.
Maybe you have, or actually certainly you'll
have partial information.
The question I would reflect back to you is
how could you test in the real world whether
or not this is worth pursuing, right?
So if you had pick a budget that you're willing
to lose, five grand, 10 grand, how could you
use that to determine, to test the waters,
to see if people are willing to buy whatever
you have to sell?
And so what does that mean, luxury mug business?
Right?
If you're selling mugs for 500 to a thousand
per mug, I don't know what changes in order
to make it a luxury mug business.
Does that mean $5,000 per mug?
Okay, fine.
10,000, whatever the number is.
There are people out there who will buy such
mugs.
Another question I would just add to this
is what story do these luxury mug buyers get
to tell their friends?
If you look at the contemporary art world,
you will see, I'm not saying this is the same,
but I think there are overlaps.
The story fucking matters a lot, right?
You can't just tape a banana to a wall at
Art Basel with duct tape and have no story.
There needs to be a story.
And there are many documentaries that you
could consider watching.
The Price of Everything is a documentary about
contemporary art, and I found it very, very
engaging.
And there are many contrasting styles in here.
So check it out.
Here's the description, "With unprecedented
access to pivotal artists and the white hot
market surrounding them, The Price of Everything
dives deep into the labyrinth of the contemporary
art world.
It examines the role of art and artistic passion
in today's money-driven, consumer-based society
where everything can be bought and sold."
I really enjoyed this.
I really, really enjoyed it.
So this would be another recommendation because
there's again, no need to reinvent the wheel.
I mean, these are not necessarily identically
the people you are going to be selling to,
but what does it take to sell the highest-priced
X?
Fill in the blank, whatever that is.
And in fact, some of my answers are going
to be overlapping with a question from a listener
in Brazil.
Carlos, "I'd like to know your thoughts about
how to market a product design to high profile
people, consultancy for professional soccer
players.
Which channel would you recommend?
Or are there some case studies to which you'd
refer?
Thank you for everything.
Big fan from Brazil."
Okay.
So all of the books, Carlos, this all apply
to you too, all of the books and the documentaries
I recommended would apply.
Another thing that you can do is study luxury
brands.
Figure out who their PR firms are.
Go to the PR firm websites and look at their
campaign case studies.
See what they do.
Right?
And you can learn a lot by doing this.
And you can create, in the old days, what
was called a swipe file, where you find a,
for many years, whenever an ad convinced me
to spend money I shouldn't spend.
So let's just say back when I was making 35,
40 grand a year, if an ad came across that
convinced me to buy something that was $500,
that was a lot of money to me.
And if it actually convinced me to even pick
up the phone or get online to buy it, whether
or not I completed the purchase, I would keep
that.
I would tear it out of the magazine or I would
take a photograph of it, or I would otherwise
try to record it in some fashion.
Let's say it was a radio advertisement.
I'd try to remember the text and type it out
and I would create a three ring binder of
all the things that almost or did convince
me to spend in an inordinate, let's just call
it unreasonable percentage of my after tax
income.
And that is another thing that you can start
to do now.
You do not need to be a professional market
analyst to do this, you just need to be aware
of your own behavior and what drives you to
purchase decisions or near purchase decisions.
So just to reiterate something I just said,
brands you admire that do a good job, campaigns
that are doing a good job or individuals who
are doing a good job with selling into luxury
markets.
Study what they do, figure out who their publicists
are, figure out who their PR firms are, and
then study those publicists and PR firms.
Most of the time, both of those categories
are going to be providing campaign examples
and so on.
You may even be able to get on the phone to
have an exploratory conversation with these
people.
All right, so those are a number of examples.
The other question that is worth reflecting
back, and this applies to Joel as well as
Carlos, that I reverse engineer a lot for
myself, is set the price first and then make
it worth it.
So for instance, when I had an event, and
I never do events.
I never produce events.
They're such a pain in the ass, but I did
produce one very high end event and I decided
that I wanted to charge, I think it was minimum
$10,000 a seat, and then it went up from there.
So the sooner somebody bought the less expensive
it was, and then it just went up in price.
So the minimum was $10,000.
I started with that as a nice round number,
and it was, I think a two or three-day event.
Then I thought to myself, All right, I want
to charge $10,000.
How can I deliver that much value in the first
two hours that people are there, so that I
don't have to worry about it?
How can I overdeliver in such a way in the
first hour or two that everything else is
gravy?
Everyone is thrilled they came within the
first two hours.
That's a creative exercise, and I was able
to pull it off.
That is because I decided on an ultra high
luxury price and then asked myself, How on
earth can I make it worth it?
What are the different ideas I have for making
it worth it?
Ultimately, it came down to sharing the actual
book proposals that I used for The 4-Hour
Workweek and The 4-Hour Body in entirety with
a few things redacted just for sensitivity,
and then also acting as a matchmaker for everyone
in the room for the period of about an hour
to 90 minutes.
After that, I mean, everybody was set in some
respect.
For those people who might want to borrow
this format, each person got up and the format
was give a brag.
You have to give a brag about yourself, so
you have to brag in some way.
Then you have an ask, and then you have a
give.
So everybody in the audience, I think there
were a hundred or 120 people got up and said,
This is who I am.
Here's one thing I want to brag about, or
maybe I don't want to brag about, but since
it's a directive, I will brag about.
Here's one thing that is an ask.
This is what I'm looking for.
And then here's one thing that I can give
that I'm really good at, or relationships
that I have, expertise, whatever it might
be.
I just encouraged everybody to take notes.
If you can help somebody who has an ask, go
help them.
If you need something that they have on offer,
because that's a give, go find them.
The rest of the event took care of itself.
But I would not have come up with those answers
had I not asked the right question.
It comes down to the right question.
So start with the price that makes it work.
Joel, luxury mug business.
What does that mean?
How many mugs at what price?
Let's just say your goal is a hundred thousand
dollars a year.
Well, the answer could take many, many, many,
many different forms.
Is it a thousand?
Well, let me step back.
We'll make it a million dollars.
Let's get ambitious, million dollars a year.
That could be a thousand mugs at a thousand
dollars a piece.
It could be one mug at a million dollars,
or it could be somewhere in the middle.
How can you mitigate risk in these experiments?
Well, look, if you look at different examples
of collaborations, you have, for instance,
CryptoPunks, now owned by Yuga Labs, partnering
with Tiffany to create bedazzled, customized
CryptoPunk jewelry.
How the fuck do these things happen?
It's worth digging into, trying to find out
how those things happen.
What are the mechanics?
What are the agreements?
What are the responsibilities of the various
parties?
Not to belabor that one example.
There are many such examples.
So for instance, how could you potentially
have one or 10 or a hundred of these go into
gift bags at the Oscars or at the Golden Globes,
or fill in the blank?
This doesn't automatically work, by the way.
I have had my books put into such bags.
Sometimes it has amazing effects, sometimes
it doesn't.
Sometimes it has amazing effects you don't
even know of until 10 years later.
So be prepared to play the long game if you're
going to do anything like that.
You have to be prepared for your investment
to go to zero.
So if your material cost and your labor cost
is 10 grand, maybe it's worth rolling the
dice.
If it's a hundred grand, maybe not, depending
on your financial picture.
Okay, there we go.
So, that's that.
I'm going to come back to the live feed.
Who knew I had so much to say about PR and
marketing?
It's been a while.
Hopefully this is helpful for folks.
All right, let's get into the live stuff.
I'm just going to keep going guys.
I'm having fun.
So if you guys are having fun, I will keep
going.
We're about an hour and 13 minutes in.
I'm happy to keep going.
I've got my iced tea, so let me know if you're
having a good time and I will keep going.
This luxury mug example should not be dismissed
if you are in a different business.
Even if you are in a SaaS business, software
as a service, enterprise SaaS, you might think
this has nothing to do with me.
It has everything to do with you potentially,
depending on your pricing tiers, depending
on your funnel, depending on what stage your
company is currently slogging through, right?
If you've already reached escape velocity
and you have all your pricing structures and
you have your entire sales force, maybe not.
But if you're trying to land the first SAP-like
customer, maybe it has everything to do with
you.
So the principles apply very, very widely.
All right, let's get in here.
"Go, Timmy, go!"
Thank you, Ellie.
I'm going.
Ryan: "Any new favorite travel spots to recommend?"
Honestly, I've been spending a lot of time
in the US.
The US has so much to offer.
And as a young whippersnapper, my early twenties,
it's easy to fantasize about everything else
in the world while neglecting all the treasures
right in your backyard.
So treasures could range from North Carolina
and the Smokies to getting to, let's say British
Columbia or the Pacific Northwest and the
rainforests in the Pacific Northwest, or going
to the Southwest, going to places like Moab.
There's so much diversity and beauty in the
United States.
I've really been trying to pay more attention
to what is in the US most recently.
All right, Nick, "The hair band video is a
great addition to that 5-Bullet Friday email."
I'm glad you enjoyed that.
That was a music video from the BulletBoys,
which I listened to when I was probably 12
years old, and I just thought I have to include
this video.
"Money, Money, money, money."
I think that was related to the Beanie Babies
bullet as well.
All right.
"Ah, Satriani."
Yeah, Russell, Satriani is amazing.
What a shredder.
So is Steve Vai.
Love to connect with those guys sometime.
All right, let me take a look what we got
here.
All right, Josh, I'll keep this short, but
if you wanted to displace/outcompete an established
tech company with a similar product, how would
you approach it from a marketing lens, assuming
you had no influence on product?
This is going to sound funny.
It's straight from The 22 Immutable Laws of
Marketing, but I would study Avis.
"We try harder" versus Hertz way back in the
day.
The strategy was more sophisticated than just
that tagline.
If you're truly similar and undifferentiated,
I think you're going to have a hard time,
and you're probably going to have to compete
on price, which is a dangerous game because
incumbents with much more money can say, You
know what?
We have 12 product lines.
We don't like this competitor.
We don't want competition, so we are just
going to sell below our cost for a period
of time to bleed them of chips until they
go out of business.
This is a very, very textbook common competitive
approach that incumbents use to spectacular
success against startups.
So it is a risky gambit to compete on price,
but that may be necessary at least for a period
of time.
But beyond that, in terms of out competing
or out marketing, I would say you could do
that on a whole lot of different levels.
I would study the Avis versus Hertz example,
and you could also study, for instance — now
this is going to be a price dominant example,
but I read the biography.
It may have been the autobiography of the
founder of Ryanair at one point, and looked
at, even though I have no interest in participating
in the airline businesses, looking at how
low cost competitors and carriers entered
the scene and became at least at points as
dominant as they did.
easyJet is another very, very interesting
example.
Certainly Southwest, another fascinating example,
and I would encourage you to look at all of
those, even though they may not seem immediately
applicable.
So those are a few approaches that you might
take.
But the commonality here is looking for comparables,
not just within your industry, but outside
of your industry.
So which startups can you model that have
taken on incumbents with similar products?
Hopefully not entirely identical, but somewhat
similar products.
You can also use — I'm not saying you have
to do this, but sort of humor and sass is
generally going to get neutralized and killed
in any bureaucracy within a bigger company,
which is why, say, Dollar Shave Club and others
had a tremendous window of opportunity that
they took excellent advantage of with their
advertising campaigns.
I think even though one could consider certainly
Richard Branson, an incumbent in some respects,
and he's certainly not having to bootstrap
things with limited savings.
If you look at how he competed, and this is
chronicled quite a bit in Losing My Virginity,
which was one of the books that had a huge
impact on me when I was in my early twenties.
So Losing My Virginity by Richard Branson
talks about competing in the music business,
and it also talks about competing against
British Airways with Virgin.
So it's just happenstance, I suppose, that
a lot of these examples are airlines, but
in a sense, airlines are the perfect example
of largely undifferentiated competition.
So it might provide some variables and levers
that you can pull and play with.
"Tea over coffee these days," from Ryan.
My rule is one.
I get one coffee in the morning these days.
Coffee really keeps me up late at night, more
so than it should, given the caffeine content.
I can have an equivalent amount of caffeine
through other sources, whether it's even energy
drinks or iced tea, and it will not keep me
up in the way that coffee does.
So as it stands right now, I'm having one
cold brew from Starbucks in the morning before
10:00 a.m.
That's a rule.
And then after that, it's iced tea.
Am I cold?
I'm being asked beanie and hoodie.
Yeah, it's fucking freezing where I am.
So yeah, I'm cold and I'm bald, so hence the
beanie.
All right, let's keep going.
All right, from Jeff, "Steve Vai would be
an awesome interview Vai's unbelievable and
spiritual."
I believe it.
I've seen him interviewed.
He's excellent.
So maybe that'll happen at some point.
All right.
I am looking at live chat, looking at live
chat.
All messages are visible.
Let me see if anything changes when I toggle
this a little bit.
Okay, Justin asks, "Any comments or observations
on limiting alcohol intake?"
I have been limiting alcohol intake quite
a bit.
I actually have had my first drinks in a month,
beginning three or four days ago.
So in prep for the higher altitude and extensive
hiking and so on, I did not want to compromise
my sleep getting ready for that.
I thought it would be a good aesthetic practice/proof
of non-dependence to take a 30-day break from
alcohol.
So I took a 30-day break from alcohol, felt
great.
I know that alcohol, especially once it gets
past two drinks, obliterates sleep.
So I have experimented with other options.
Number one is simply not having alcohol, just
having peppermint tea or whatever I might
want to have for flavor at a dinner, which
is perfectly fine most of the time.
I'm also looking at other options.
There are some keto beverages, which are non
ethanol-based alcoholic beverages, if that
makes any sense.
Where you can actually get a buzz from, say,
I think it's R Butane dial or (R) 1, 3 butanediol.
Let me just see what — yeah, so 1, 3 butanediol,
also known as (R) 1, 3 butanediol, is not
great in my experience for performance at
all, but it can give you a slight buzz.
And please do not — this is not food consumption
advice.
1,3 butanediol is used mainly as a solvent
for food flavors.
So FYI, right?
So there are a number of brands that sell
(R) butane 1, 3 diol.
I'm mixing up all of my chemistry here.
So there are some brands that sell hard keto
drinks, and I have been experimenting with
those as an alternative to ethanol based drinks,
like a gin tonic or something like that.
It does seem like the hard keto drinks, if
consumed close to bedtime, will still negatively
affect sleep.
So if I consume alcohol, I try to do, whether
it's the hard ketones or ethanol, I try to
consume it on the early side.
So if I'm having an early dinner, say 5:30
or 6:00, I want to give my body and my liver
time to metabolize as much as possible before
I lay down to bed.
That means I'll go out to dinner.
If I'm going to have a drink, as I did yesterday
for instance — actually, I had two glasses
of wine last night and I sat at the bar instead
of at a table so I wouldn't be rushed.
I had two drinks while writing for about 30
minutes before getting my food.
Because what I didn't want to do is have one
drink with an appetizer, eat a huge entree,
and have two or three more drinks just to
feel the buzz.
Ultimately, all of that lands on my system
and needs to be dealt with.
So those are a few of the thoughts I have,
but I have dramatically cut back on my alcohol
content or I have dramatically cut back on
my alcohol consumption, and that might change
depending on where I go.
If I'm going to Italy and I'm going to be
eating pasta and drinking wine everywhere,
then I'm going to drink wine everywhere.
It's not a big deal to me.
But as it stands right now, I have cut back
very substantially.
All right.
Stephanie suggests visiting Shaved Ice Island
in South Austin.
Life changing Thai tea shaved ice on the menu.
I'm into it.
I will check it out.
All right, Sheri, I think is the name here.
I hope I'm getting that down properly.
"With your various endeavors into hobbies,
have you ever tried archery?
And if so, any directions as to books, teachers,
et cetera, to check out?
Specifically looking at traditional longbow?"
Yes, I have looked quite closely at archery,
and I've been spending the last several months
going deep down quite a few rabbit holes related
to archery.
I have one, two, three, four, five — five
or six bows.
No, more, seven, eight, probably eight bows
within 500 feet of where I'm sitting.
So yes, I've been getting into it.
That includes a traditional longbow made by
someone named Byron Ferguson, who has a lot
of incredible video online.
I believe Byron has a book called Become the
Arrow.
Let me see, Yeah, Become the Arrow, second
edition by Byron Ferguson.
He has some of the most incredible longbow
shots I've ever seen.
He is the one, as far as I know, who was first
to develop the trick shot progression of shooting
a disc out of the air that is about the size
of, say, a bread plate, and then shooting
a golf ball out of the air, and then shooting
a lifesaver out of the air, and then shooting
an aspirin out of the air using field points.
So he's quite incredible.
Longbow, I think is very, very interesting,
very, very challenging also.
I am quite interested in both Olympic recurve
and bear bow competition.
So I'm looking at both of those.
Most of my experience from a precision standpoint
is with compound bows.
But from the looking at a spectrum of say,
aiming.
Let's just call it aiming on one end of the
slider and then biomechanics on the far other
end of the slider, I would say that compound
bow, for me at least, has the most in common
with rifle or firearm marksmanship.
So if I were going to train someone for compound,
and I'm not a professional by any means, but
just to help someone get accustomed to breath
control and aligning front rear sites, I would
actually have them start with prone rifle
shooting and move from there to compound.
There are a million different types of releases.
We won't get into that, but if you have compound
there, and then on the far other end of the
spectrum with biomechanics, you have longbow,
then I would put something like Olympic recurve
close to the middle, I would say.
And then bear bow would be somewhere between
the Olympic recurve and the longbow.
But the further you get to the biomechanics
side, the better your shot sequence.
People are going to disagree with me on this,
but the more you get to the biomechanics side,
the better your body awareness and kinesthetic
control and sequencing of your shot sequence
will need to be.
I think that's probably most easily illustrated
by watching video of say, Korean archers in
Olympic recurve.
They're just unbelievably good.
So take a look at that.
But yes, I'm very interested in archery is
the short answer.
Here's a question from Joel.
"You and Steve Pressfield talked about writing
fiction on your podcast.
Did that inspire your NFT or have you tried
other fiction writing?"
I have tried other fiction writing.
So there are a number of pieces that are unpublished,
short stories that I have not shared, which
are fiction, mostly because they're not complete.
These are longer short stories.
Then the first fiction piece I ever published
was put out as my first experimental NFT with
Kevin Rose.
If people want to check that out, you can
read it online.
There's no issue with doing that.
If you just go to tim.blog/nft, you can go
on and just zoom in and read that story.
If holders of that NFT are open to it at some
point, I may just put three quarters
as well.
But I have tried other fiction writing to
answer your question.
So this is a question from Cindy.
"When unexpected life or people/challenges
try and knock you down, what go to tools help
you keep grounded?"
I think that's what you're asking.
"Are there two to three podcast guests who
brought those tools?"
Yes.
I would say the people who come to mind are
immediately, first off the top of my head
— and there are more.
One would be Tara Brach, who wrote an incredible
book called Radical Acceptance.
So I'd say Tara Brach is definitely one.
Another would be Jerry Colonna, who has a
number of questions that I think are fantastic
and worth keeping in mind constantly, including
how am I complicit in creating the conditions
I say I don't want?
That would be one example of many.
So we have Tara Brach, Jerry Colonna, and
then I'll throw in Jack Kornfield.
All of his interviews I think are very, very
powerful.
The reason I bring those three up is that
when I feel I have been hit unexpectedly with
something, or perhaps I have precipitated
something happening that is undesirable, my
defaults, and I think this is from a lot of
family history as well, are anger.
Mostly anger directed at myself, but anger
and self-flagellation.
Just incredible and beating myself up mercilessly.
For those reasons, I mention those guests
because for me, it's not the events that are
the problem per se.
It's my reflexive response to those events
being self-abuse through inner monologue or
dialogue and being able to, number one, create
a greater awareness of that.
Number two, developing, or borrowing in these
cases, toolkits and questions that allow me
to calm that reactivity and not to push it
away necessarily, but certainly in the case
of Tara Brach, to befriend in a way, to have
a conversation with it or with those parts
is very helpful.
Another person I would add to that is Richard
Schwartz, who is the founder of IFS.
I had him on the podcast.
So those are the first few names that come
to mind.
Andrew: "Proud holder."
Cool.
Let me know if you think it would be a good
idea.
I think it could be interesting for me to
share the actual text from the fictional short
story in the NFT.
Let me know what you think.
I'll keep an eye on the chat.
All right.
Christopher has a question.
"Which mental model or helpful tool do you
often go back to regarding prioritizing projects
and things you want to pursue?"
I'll keep it at that.
So I have one really simple question that
echos also a guest I've had on, Let me just
get this right, Bear with me a second.
I want to give proper attribution here.
Okay, so I do have one question and there's
a very good chance that I adapted this from
Gary Keller.
So Gary is legendary in the world of real
estate.
He is the co-founder, chairman, and CEO of
Keller Williams, the world's largest real
estate franchise by agent count.
2019 KW, which also ranks number one in units
and sales volume in the US was named by Fast
Company as the most innovative company in
real estate.
So Gary is a fascinating, fascinating character.
You can find him on Twitter @GaryKeller.
The name of this podcast episode is "How to
Focus on the One Important Thing."
"Gary Keller — How to Focus on the One Important
Thing."
I'd recommend folks listen to this.
He also has a book called The ONE Thing, subtitled
The Surprisingly Simple Truth Behind Extra
Extraordinary Results.
I believe the question that I ask myself is
adapted from this, but I can't say that with
a hundred percent certainty.
That question is this.
In this list of things, five or six or 10
things, whatever your list of priorities might
be or to dos, which of these, if done, make
other things or all of these things, either
irrelevant or easier to do?
So look at this list of 10 things.
Which of these, if done, make other items
on this list?
Hopefully many or all of them, easier to do
or irrelevant.
That is my sorting function.
That's it.
Now, on top of that, let's just say that doesn't
yield the clarity I'm hoping for.
I could look at that list again and ask myself,
which of these, if done or brought to the
next milestone, would leave me feeling proudest
at the end of the day?
I know people who do this with workouts.
I know CrossFit champions who do this with
certain types of workouts.
Just asking yourself, which of these, if done
or pushed to the next milestone, would lead
me feeling proudest at the end of the day?
That's another one.
A third would be if you're trying to choose
between, say, major projects.
So you've got this branching tree and you
have three different professional options.
Let's just say different projects, different
endeavors, joint ventures, whatever, creative
projects.
I'll ask myself, which of these, even if it
fails, can be the greatest success?
That's a success in terms of new skills, new
relationships or deepened relationships, and
also just energy.
Which of these will give me the most energy,
will I be most energized by?
So I'll repeat that.
Three options, having trouble choosing between
them.
Let's just say they're creative projects.
Which of these can be a success for me, even
if it fails?
Let's say the launch doesn't work, people
don't want to buy it, whatever it is.
In terms of new skills or directing old skills,
in the case of me choosing my new absurd art
project, as a resurrecting old skills.
So resurrecting old skills or developing new
skills, developing new relationships, or deepening
current relationship, and then providing life
energy, energizing you.
That is how I've decided to spend so much
time over the last, say, six to 12 months
on this hair brained thing that'll come out
in the next few months, which absolutely could
be a flop on every commercial/financial level.
So that's part of what makes it kind of exciting
to me, honestly.
So we'll see how it goes.
John said, "The lead domino."
Exactly.
Choosing the right domino to tip over that
tips over many others.
Bill has a question.
"Did the book Four Thousand Weeks change your
approach to life and living in any way?"
I thought Four Thousand Weeks was an exceptional
book, and I plan to go back and reread it.
I have a lot of Kindle highlights and shared
one chapter in particular from that book on
the blog, on tim.blog called "Cosmic Insignificance
Therapy."
So if you want to read that chapter, I encourage
everybody to read it.
"Cosmic Insignificance Therapy."
You can find that on tim.blog.
All right, since we're at an hour and 40 minutes,
I'm going to do a handful of additional questions
on the pre-submitted and we'll see where it
goes.
All right.
Okay, this is a question from Al.
"If you had to build a launch strategy for
The 4-Hour Workweek in 2022 versus 20007,
otherwise known, 2007, what strategies and
channels would you employ?
Which strategies would stay consistent from
2007 and why?"
I think the crux decision, which was to engage
with people in person at events, at the time,
those were predominantly bloggers.
Now that might be different, but not necessarily.
Blogs are still actually a thing, despite
what people may think.
But that core approach to taking the uncrowded
channel of engaging with people in person
at events, in recreational settings over drinks
would remain consistent.
You could remove every other prong of The
4-Hour Workweek launch strategy.
If I simply executed well again on that type
of in person engagement, I think the book
would still be a success today.
To reiterate how I did that, or to give one
example, I would go to the after party after
some conference event where people are on
panels, and sometimes I would approach them
afterwards.
Very often when I would approach a panel,
I would not approach the panelists who are
getting mobbed.
I would approach the moderator who is deservedly
neglected a lot of times in cases like this,
and chat with the moderator, usually asking
a handful of follow up questions, which are
sincere questions about the topics on the
panel.
They would at some point generally ask me,
"Well, what are you doing here?
Why are you here?"
And I would say, "It's my first time at this
event.
I've just finished writing my first book.
It's this, this, and this.
It's based on guest lectures I gave at Princeton
University from 2000 x to 2000 y.
I'm trying to figure out how to launch a book
since it's really on me.
The publisher effectively prints and ships
books.
I have to figure out how to market this.
Is there anyone you think I might want to
meet?
Is there anyone you think I might get along
with?"
Then they would make a referral and I would
be on to the next referral.
I would repeat something like that each time.
Separately, if I came upon, say, a group of
people, bloggers, let's just say.
I knew at least one blogger was in this group,
at a bar.
They'd be talking, and I would wander up and
I would say something like, "Hey, guys, do
you mind if I join in and just listen in?"
And they'd be like, "Whatever.
Fine."
And so I'd hang out and if I finish my drink
first, I'd be like, "Hey, does anyone else
need a drink?"
Don't be a fucking weirdo, just be a normal
person.
But anyway, "Hey, does anyone else need a
drink?
I'm going to grab another one."
"Okay, great."
Get a couple drinks.
And eventually somebody in the group would
be like, "What's your story?
Who are you?
Why are you here?"
And I would give some answer along the lines
of what I just mentioned.
And then I would just stop.
I would not start pitching.
I would not immediately start humping their
legs to ask them if they wanted to read an
advanced copy or something like that.
But I would say that, and then I would leave
the window open to more questions, and then
I would see if anyone took the bait.
And if they did, that is an indicator of,
at least I took it as an indicator of interest.
So let's say one of the people's like, "Well,
okay, so you said your book is — what's
the book about?"
And then I would elaborate.
Then maybe they would ask some follow-up questions.
And then at some point I would offer, I would
simply say, "Look, it might not be of any
interest to you.
I totally understand if you're just too busy.
But there are I think maybe one or two chapters
that would be really interesting to you.
If you'd like, I have a ton of advanced copies.
I could just send you a copy and put in some
post-it notes for the 20 pages or so that
I think would be most interesting."
And I would say, I don't know, 60, 70 percent
of the time that I went up to one of those
groups, at least one person would be like,
"Yeah, that sounds cool.
Yeah, totally.
Yeah, please send it."
And that is a high-labor approach that also
can have a very, very high ROI.
And I would replicate that.
I still think in-person is the least crowded.
It just takes a set of skills that most people
have neglected I think in a world where everything
is thought to be digital and text first via
email.
The interpersonal piece I think gets lost
a bit and the ability to navigate social dynamics
in a way that is interesting, but not overwhelming
or irritating takes practice.
You've got to practice this stuff.
And fortunately, I got a lot of practice doing
that on the phone and in-person in my first
job out of college, which was being an outside
sales rep for fiber channel storage area networks,
I had to learn how to navigate this stuff.
So in-person, it still works or it can work.
All right, let me check out some more questions
in the live chat.
We'll see what we got here.
Okay, so Andrew, on the "How to Start a War."
Why don't you just chat with the folks and
prove who are holders and see what they think."
I don't see the downside, I really don't.
I think it all that we'll do is draw attention
to it and increase interest in it.
I don't see the downside and I certainly don't
have to share all of it.
It could be, I don't know, 70 or 80 percent.
Okay, here's a question.
"What's your gut response to the metaverse
and its potential use cases?"
Very conflicted.
I think as much as people talk about the utopia
and ideology of decentralization, humans like
centralized discovery or some centralized
service where they do not need to make decisions.
Humans are fucking lazy.
And I'll throw myself in there too, honestly.
Discovery is hard and humans want to identify
tastemakers or curators to help them with
making choices in areas of high complexity
or in situations where there is a paradox
of choice challenge, which is almost everywhere.
And this will certainly be true in the metaverse
or the metaverses, although I find that oxymoronic,
I guess, when we start looking at it that
way.
So I do think that there will be likely a
handful at most of virtual spaces like the
metaverse in Snow Crash, let's say, where
people interact through avatars.
So let's just call it in a Second Life on
mega steroids with all sorts of technological
innovations that have started to crest in
the last handful of years.
I find it hard to believe that there are going
to be dozens and dozens and dozens of these
things.
I find it hard to believe that that will be
compelling to users if a few dominant players
with massive amounts of capital and employee
coordination are focused on creating the most
addictive compelling versions of these spaces.
I hope I'm wrong, but if I've noticed anything
in the last year or two, it's that people
claim to hate centralization, but man, do
they love it.
It saves them a lot of time and it saves them
a lot of decisions.
So we'll see where it goes.
Oh yeah, okay.
Elrique, "How is your gardening going?
Did you get this gardening season?
If yes, what worked and what not?
There's nothing like trying experimenting."
So yes, the answer is the gardening has worked.
Hold on a second.
So I'm holding up a huge basket of veggies,
and this came right out of my garden, few
hundred feet away.
We've got these beautiful beans that are purple
in color, but you could eat them whole.
They're absolutely delicious.
Then we have these amazing, huge beets.
So check that out.
We're going to be eating a bunch of those
later today.
We've got the biggest, check out the size
of these things, the biggest Swiss chard you
can imagine.
Look at this.
That's Swiss chard.
It's the size of my entire upper torso.
So it did work this year, and I'd say the
two main differences are relocating the raised
beds so they have more consistent sun exposure.
But above and beyond that two things, setting
up a very, very simple electric fence that
can be turned off and on.
It's solar powered and it's very, very thin
meshed.
It's just to keep out, to the extent possible,
the deer, the groundhog, all this kind of
stuff.
And then second is an aeration system, a timed
watering system.
So simple, not that difficult to install.
And the combination of all those factors has
led to just an incredible harvest this year,
for the first time ever in my life, tons and
tons of stuff.
For whatever reason, the kale gets annihilated
by pests.
Everything else is fine and intact, the kale
gets completely killed.
I'm not using any pesticides, but for some
reason, the kale specifically is just the
sacrificial lamb.
It seems to get absolutely naced by everything
that wants to snack on some domesticated veggies.
So there you have it, but thanks for asking.
I can feel my brain slowing down a little
bit, guys, so I'm probably going to do another
10 to 15 minutes.
All right.
Ranjit: "What is your workout routine these
days?"
My workout routine's super simple.
I go to the gym and I lift weights doing full-body
workouts, and it's called twice a week.
That's weight training.
I have a sled, a weighted sled that I push,
I would say three to four times per week in
the morning, usually after my first cold brew.
And I am intermittent fasting at the moment
where I will effectively not have anything
to eat until noon.
I say effectively because sometimes I will
have a few macadamia nuts or something like
that.
But generally no calories to very, very low
calories.
So I'm intermittent fasting in the morning
and am doing kettlebell swings.
Right now I think I'm using a 72-pounder for
sets of 50 and really just doing one set of
50 to a hundred reps twice a week.
And I jump rope in the mornings oftentimes
before I do the sled pushing just as a way
to wake up my nervous system and my cognition,
honestly, just jumping rope for two minutes,
hopping around, having my dog bark her face
off at me, which is hilarious, is enough to
change my mood, to elevate mood.
Sauna, probably four to five times a week,
generally before dinner.
So let's just say I'm eating at seven o'clock.
I will finish up my day, my work day at five
or 5:30, do the sauna for a half hour, and
then take a cold shower post.
That's about it.
It's nothing crazy.
If I go for a hike with my dog, which I do
pretty regularly, if the weather permits,
I will throw on a rucksack.
I have a GORUCKsack for an hour hike.
I'm not using crazy weight also because this
rucksack does not have a waist strap.
So I am supporting all the weight on my traps
and shoulders usually use 35 pound weight.
But you'll notice none of this takes more
than — the weight training at the gym is
going to take the most time because of the
transit.
There are weeks when I just skip that all
together and I'll do the other things I described,
but we're talking about at most 30 minutes
a day, unless it's an activity that doesn't
function for me exclusively as exercise, like
an hour long hike with my dog, then I'm just
throwing on weights to get some additional
stimulation.
But that's what the workout looks like these
days.
I am using a new device that I've enjoyed.
I'll just go grab them to show what they look
like.
Okay, so for decreasing lower back pain or
alleviating lower back pain and also helping
tremendously with sleep, there are two devices
that I've been using for some time now.
This one is called the Pso-Rite, and you lay
on top of this, and for those who can't see
this, it is a piece of plastic that looks
almost like a U. And the tops of either side
of the U are these rounded plastic ridges
that you lay on top of and they apply pressure
to your psoas.
So this is called a Pso-Rite device, pso-rite.com.
And this is a device that I used last night,
for instance, prior to sleep.
And I've been comparing and contrasting that
with another option, which is a lot easier
to travel with.
So I have traveled, for instance, when I was
hiking in the mountains and at altitude, I
traveled with this.
So if you look at this thing here, this is
the Hip Hook and it more effectively gets
into, and you can see how aggressive this
looks, right?
You're laying on this.
So this really gets into your psoas and can
also get to the iliacus more effectively than
the Pso-Rite.
I'm not an anatomist, but if you think of
where your psoas is, let's just say a few
inches up from your iliac crest, those hip
bones that stick out right under your obliques
or love handles depending on your condition,
those hips, if you go directly up your sides
and then towards the center, say, I don't
know, three or four inches, and then press
directly towards your spine, this is not a
precise description, but you will be getting
into your psoas.
The iliopsoas.
The iliacus is going to be lower down, inside
the cradle of the hip architecture, which
is where the Hip Hook comes in.
And this really works well, I've been using
it for the last several weeks on the road.
And these two I have found to be tremendously
helpful for improving sleep.
Often what disrupts my sleep is lower back
tightness and I end up having to flip flop
like a rotisserie chicken from side to side
to side to side, which, surprise, surprise,
does not improve your sleep architecture or
quality.
So these two devices I have found very helpful.
Let me do another question here from Michael.
"What would be your suggested criteria for
choosing podcast to allocate advertising dollars
towards product/industry agnostic if possible?"
This is a difficult question to answer.
I would say because there are a number of
articles that have been written about it.
Athletic Greens has the most methodical, quantitative
and strategic approach to podcast advertising
that I have ever seen in any company.
So to the extent that you can study that,
and there are articles that discuss their
approach to podcast advertising, I think it
is it worth looking at.
It is not possible, I think, to make any answer
product/industry agnostic because Athletic
Greens has a high-end premium product with
a very high LTV, customer lifetime value.
And you can timebound that, let's just say
their value over two years or three years,
something like that.
But it is a product that has a very low amount
of churn.
In other words, once someone subscribes to
receive Athletic Greens, they tend to remain
an Athletic Greens user.
And this is the type of product that I think
is particularly well-suited to certain types
of podcasts, especially long form interview
podcasts where ad reads are host-read.
Very specific I know, but Athletic Greens
is worth studying.
And then an additional factor that is less
discussed.
Because on the buy side, if you are a podcast
advertiser, generally you don't want to allocate,
you don't want to discuss the implicit value
of what I'm going to describe because it lessens
your bargaining position.
If you're on the buy side for the podcast
equation, you want to say, "Okay, here is
our URL with a code at the end," and people
are going to go to this link.
We're going to track how much traffic goes
to that link.
And then they need to enter this really onerous
code.
It's TIM08#43_7, and based on how many people
redeem that code, we will see what the ROI
is on our podcasting advertisement.
Now anyone listening to the exaggerated example
I just gave will realize there's going to
be a tremendous amount of slippage.
What does this mean?
This means that the vast majority of people
aren't going to remember, nor even if they
remember take the time to input such a code
if the savings is for instance, say 10 percent,
which is why I almost always insist that if
sponsors are going to give a discount, they
make it compelling enough so that people will
use an actual tracking code.
Because if they are setting the measure of
success based on a code, which most people
will not put in, unless the discount is significant
30 to 50 percent, then I am being set up for
failure.
Because, especially this is true with larger
companies, if there is someone who's a middle
manager, junior VP of marketing, or associate
director of marketing who is in charge of
monitoring ROI and they're basing everything
on, say, the one out of 10 people I refer
who actually fill in a code, then they are
deliberately or unknowingly putting themselves
in a position to say the podcast ad didn't
work.
This fortunately doesn't happen very often
with me, but I'm painting a picture that is
something that applies all over the industry.
So there are a couple of things here to keep
in mind, right?
There's slippage number one, you're not going
to track anything perfectly.
Unless it goes through something like a newsletter,
in which case, now I have access to the data
as well.
I can look at the click-through rates and
I can identify, for instance, is it a copy
issue?
Is it a read issue?
Or, and this is very common, is it a website
conversion issue?
My team spends quite a bit of time with podcast
advertisers looking at their websites saying,
"Hey, look, we can send a bunch of fish towards
your net, but your net sucks.
It's full of holes right now.
Doesn't make any sense.
It's upside down and we're not going to do
it unless your conversion can be optimized."
We're more polite about it than that, but
it's critical that I think for me at least,
because I care about having long term sponsors
for extended periods of time, it's a hassle
and very energy intensive for my team to deal
with any type of churn that I want, all pieces
of the chain to function optimally before
I put forth the effort to test all these products
and services and then vet them down to the
top five percent that make the cut.
And then to do a good read.
I don't want to go through all that hassle
if someone's not going to do the heavy lifting
on their side to ensure optimal conversion.
I know we're getting a little off topic, but
the reason that I bring all of this up is
allocating advertising dollars.
How should you allocate advertising dollars?
There are different reasons you may advertise,
and I'll give an example.
There was a billboard in the Bay Area, it
was on 280, which takes people from the airport,
from SFO to San Francisco, and there's this
big billboard and it was a huge tech company.
I'm not going to mention the name because
I don't know if they'd like it, but the advertisement
didn't really make any sense to anyone, except
for one tiny sliver of the population.
Huge billboard, no doubt, very expensive.
And lots of people drove by it and they're
like, "That's the dumbest billboard ever.
It doesn't even make any sense."
And then someone in this group conversation
said, "Actually, it makes perfect sense.
You just have to realize who that billboard
is for.
It is for investment bankers who are visiting
the Bay Area.
That's it."
So if you're looking at that billboard for
conversion purposes and there's some unique
URL, the value is probably going to amount
to zero.
If you are looking at it from a customer acquisition
perspective, and this was a gaming company,
the value is probably zero if you're viewing
it.
However, through the lens of courting the
top operators in the rarefied world of investment
banking, okay now perhaps you only need one
person or two people or five people to pay
attention to that, and suddenly that can be
worth many millions upon millions of dollars
for a given company.
The reason I bring that up is you should ask
yourself, who do I want to know this brand?
Who do I want to understand the marketing
positioning of this brand?
Is it for instance, the broadest population
possible, say all readers of USA Today and
all viewers of late night television, something
like that?
Or is it most valuable for me to get in front
of, say, the audience of TED?
Would I want just the two to 3,000 people
at TED to all be aware of this?
And that can dictate your choice of platform.
So if you want to say, get in front of New
York Times, Wall Street Journal, policymakers,
tastemakers, directors, producers, et cetera,
I know for a fact that you can very easily
do that through the podcast, my podcast that
is, or through 5-Bullet Friday, through the
newsletter, right?
And that is highly, highly, highly targeted.
The absolute numbers may not be large, even
though the newsletter's got two million subscribers
or so.
In the grand scheme of things, in a country
of whatever, the 350 to 400 million people,
that's not a gigantic percentage, but you
don't need a gigantic percentage, if similar
to our earlier conversations, you choose the
right lead dominoes.
And this maps perfectly to how I launched
The 4-Hour Workweek also, in choosing outlets.
How did I choose outlets?
I was looking at the first domino as the very
tightly defined demographic of say, 20- to
35-year-old tech savvy males living in New
York, San Francisco, and Los Angeles.
That was it.
And what that allowed me to do as someone
with very little budget was to take whatever
time and capital I had and to think about
four or five outlets, let's just say at the
time, probably Gizmodo, TechCrunch, Lifehacker
perhaps, and a few others.
And Robert Scoble was a very, very influential
blogger at the time, if I could get noticed
and some degree of coverage from these outlets,
I would create the perception of surround
sound in so much as I would appear with The
4-Hour Workweek to be ubiquitous to a very,
very tightly defined demographic, recognizing
that the target, the initial target market
is not the total market.
And people get all caught up about this where
they're like, "Oh God.
Well, what if we know we need to be inclusive
with everybody?"
If you try to make everyone your customer,
no one is going to be your customer.
You will fail 99 times out of a hundred.
There is a time to broaden, but it is not
in the early phases.
In the beginning, you need the strongest foothold
and handhold possible.
So you need to choose your niche.
And this is true with so many products that
end up being mainstream successes.
They do not begin by trying to boil the ocean
at once.
They choose a very surgical, precise demographic.
So I started with that, and the expectation
was if I were able to establish a critical
mass of attention within that group, that
it would then cascade.
It would cascade from male to female.
Now you have 20- to 35-year-old tech-savvy
females in the same cities looking at the
same outlets, and that is exactly what happened.
And then from there, the age would start to
bleed out and creep both younger and older.
That's exactly what happened.
And then from there, from those cities with
very high density and large populations, including
a critical mass of people with broadcast capabilities,
let's say bloggers, people using Twitter,
et cetera, which launched publicly officially
at the same South by Southwest that The 4-Hour
Workweek did in March of 2007, that if you
choose the right initial dominoes, you can
allow cascades to take care of a lot of the
heavy lifting later.
But if you are imprecise in the beginning,
you're fucked.
It just will not work.
Even if you, I had a million dollars to put
into The 4-Hour Workweek launch, and I think
I capped my total expenses at $10 or $20 grand,
almost all of which went to events registration
and travel and housing for those events, just
FYI.
But if instead of that 20 grand I'd had a
million dollars, number one, I would've made
much worse decisions, I would've been much
less precise.
I would've been much less creative.
And if I had made poor decisions in the beginning,
chosen the wrong dominoes, and then tried
to fix it, say six months later by pouring
money into it would've all been cash in a
pile lit on fire on the sidewalk.
It wouldn't have done anything.
So how the hell did we get onto all this?
Wow, I've got a preacher's fire my belly.
I don't know what happened there.
Oh yes, we were talking about suggested criteria
for choosing podcast allocate advertising
dollars towards.
All right, so there you go.
You got a long rambling sermon instead of
a short answer, but hopefully that at least
provides some questions that might be helpful
and a recognition of some of the invisible
risks and benefits of choosing through one
criterion alone.
If you run a direct-to-consume or direct-response
business, you need at least some, if not most
of your advertising to return a positive ROI
or a media efficiency ratio.
But you don't need all of it to do that.
You don't need all of it to do that.
There is some degree of brand advertising
or creation of awareness, which unfortunately
are smoke screen excuses that get used to
justify a lot of decision making.
But you can be very surgical about how you
might approach such things.
And in the very beginning, for instance, sponsoring
the UFC for my sports nutrition company was
exactly that.
I did not need the UFC to return all of my
sponsorship cost.
It was a strategic decision on a whole bunch
of different levels, and you can afford a
couple of those experiments as long as you
recognize or assume that the trackable ROI
will likely be $0, at least in the intermediate
phase.
Okay, so long answer.
This is from Bradley.
"My wife is wonderful, but she has a bad relationship
with herself.
What advice do you have for people to increase
self-love?
Thanks, Tim."
Read Radical Acceptance by Tara Brach, T-A-R-A
B-R-A-C-H, and I believe she has an online
course that also focuses on radical acceptance,
so you can take a look at that as well.
From Joel, Would I ever appear on Joe Rogan's
podcast again or would that level of exposure
bring too much unwanted fame at this point
in life?
I think it'd be fun to be on Joe's podcast
again, it was a lot of fun when I did it the
first two times very long ago.
This is before Joe Rogan was the undisputed
king of all podcasts.
So I know he has an overabundance of guest
options, but at some point, if it ever made
sense for him, I think it would be fun to
be on again.
Have I ever tried backcountry skiing?
This is from Elrique.
Could be something for you.
I just got some good recommendations in Austria.
Yes, I did my first backcountry trekking,
so with conversion skis that allow you to
lift your heel, but then lock in for downhill
last year in the Rockies, and well effectively
the Rockies in the American West and thought
it was absolutely spectacular.
I anticipated it would be more like crosscountry
skiing, which I find very awkward and slippery
and feels unstable on the knees.
But using the touring boots that allow you
to connect and disconnect or elevate the heel,
I absolutely had a blast.
So yes, I may want those recommendations in
Austria at some point, had a great time.
All right, here, I'll answer this one just
as a teaser.
So, all right, this is from Theren.
I think it's a cool name.
Hopefully I'm pronouncing it correctly.
So here is the question.
Can you give us some alpha on your NFT project
code named Project 555?
Is KevKev helping you with it?
When can we expect more about it?
Can we, the supporters group, get first access?
So all I'll say is I will confirm that Project
555 is in fact me.
So I will give you that, and there will be
a lot more coming soon.
I do have a lot of excitement, and I get giddy
just thinking about it surrounding this.
It's going to be ridiculous and completely
absurd.
I'm just going to warn everyone in advance.
It's going to make a lot of people cover their
eyes with their hands with a huge "WTF, Tim
Ferriss?"
Oh, my God.
I'm sure that some percentage will think to
themselves, "I'm so disappointed."
No doubt they'll tell me that.
The internet loves to tell people that.
"I'm so disappointed.
I expected so much more."
So, key to happiness, low expectations.
Don't expect anything other than possibly
letting out an "Oh, my fucking God!"
laugh when you see this whole thing.
So for the time being, I will just confirm
that Project 555 is in fact yours truly.
All right, guys.
Thank you so much for all the time.
Hopefully this was helpful.
I had a good time.
There are some great questions both in the
live feed and in those submitted.
And I think we will come to a close right
now at, well, I am on EST, so almost 5:55
EST, which I will take as a good omen.
All right, everybody, thank you very much
and have a wonderful evening.